so I would say at a minimum it is very
it is a path of beneficial to the
beneficial so you're trying to get to a
higher level of that skill is set up for
a particular and having a particular
means leave it at that you will find it
easier to begin this path to that
destination if you are fit and strong so
if you have to do that first I didn't
say you have to be fit strong to be
there I said you will find it beneficial
or that this end has nothing to do with
fitness is wrong but it's more
beneficial towards moving that way if
you are fit and strong the next thing is
if you can organize your body your limbs
your skeleton your muscles all the
things we recognize as Anatomy in the
Canisius kinesiology sound way you will
find it also beneficial towards
eventually reaching that goal however
that goal does not require this
kinesiology cool soundness okay
so at this drill in this level we have
to discover this soundness
biomechanical soundness okay so when I'm
here I am if I do this feels like you're
a samurai but you are not able to engage
the pelvis adequately you taking
everything into the small of your back
at the apex of that convention okay if
the guy is strong enough it just uh it
just seizes on you okay so this is my
stomach I flex I expand my elbow it's
gonna be not on the outside let's put it
on the underside nothing straight on
your side just not out slightly down you
see that and my arm I'm gonna have that
shoulder girdle they see it forward not
back
like I am having good posture you see
this you doing your Aikido out here hold
here just like you didn't even audio all
right here there's her head boom right
there turn turn turn
shoulder stays there do you see that do
you guys see that
okay back lot expanding elbow on the
other side two diagonal other side don't
let that shoulder go in there we'll push
the shoulder and keep the other side of
the line off the times with this side
droops this side
it's lat so hold cheap the other side
alive okay your thought is involved in
your biomechanics
so project past him with your mind with
your idea with your intention imagine
touching the wall that will help keep
this shoulder from doing that okay so he
goes and we just gonna hang here all day
because what he has to do is be strong
enough to do that with my shoulder do
you see that it's when I let my shoulder
do that then he can get on the outside I
can't use my pelvis in the fourth
structure okay so keep it here intention
to keep that shoulder almost like a blue
Cobras back almost okay here and he goes
and as he pushes I just keep that locked
I don't push into his ham and keep that
locked and I let that just stay expand
okay let's try that just kind of that an
analogy do you understand no come close
do what the teachers don't pay off on
the perimeter or doing your own thing
okay so Tyra Berger is a path a
beneficial path each thing you're doing
is not the thing okay so you get
confused as a debt sheet because you now
prioritize not being pushed over so he
goes to push me and I start doing this
tell me what's different in what I'm
doing here what looks different
biomechanical
my arm is almost hyper-extended do you
see that what else is different
yeah my shoulders are smaller do you see
do you see how I'm doing that okay
this was the other angle and this is the
same do you see that it was true you're
able to stop him
do you see that but this will not get
you to the next level so do not just
stop him do the form trust the method
okay so I'm here like this so what I'm
going to do now is not to make this more
enticing so you just try to stop someone
but to show you this this was not it so
what we do is we double the way so you
okay friend and then go to go like look
look I can't even get there you
see that oh I did the other and
let's do this one was his jumper
this is me trying the same biomechanical
solution I'm trying to gain leverage PC
but never gonna gain leverage there's
just no way you'll see people like right
but what I ultimately want isn't even
what is in here in this drill this is an
external alignment supported by um
isolated muscle flexion okay I'm going
to change this drill so you can see what
I'm doing keep pushing
where's my posture where's my skillet
aligned so same thing not not leverage
just up
so if I'm going to make this only about
not letting it push me you can do it
many ways you get it do it out like this
do it like this you could have done this
you stand like I push you but it won't
get you to the other truck what I said
was an external bottom Academy sound
frame is beneficial towards learning the
next step meaning it'll be easier to
learn the next step from here just like
here by mechanical sound this is easier
to learn from a fit state okay got it
but so when you start deviating you'll
pop stops you can't make the next jump
so do not prioritize him not pushing you
over
prioritize the shape the shape okay so
you go on down you see that what's the
shape you see that this is not watch
place yes elbows forward but not chest
concave boom the chest is still trying
to get out with the elbows for okay not
elbow off to the side of my body
Oh ball in front of me you see how I'm
doing that so then I'm here you can get
here so now what I want you to do is
start relaxing you'll feel they can see
how's contagion is making you stop
pushing you can't stop pushing
I just start relaxing everything that I
think was holding that armored space and
all we have is this little thing okay
after you get there I want you you don't
keep pushing you don't need you don't
need the straight line either you don't
need the straight okay you can go
wherever you okay so first some mostly
working on the bottom of the Salamis
those of us who get it start relaxing
relax the tension get some faith
dad don't need that part it's like a
game of Jenga that piece is not actually
holding a tower up okay take it out I'm
gonna try this piece oh no that one
seems it hold it let me try this piece
yep
take it out okay and then eventually
what you have is just no there's no
pieces there's no keys all this
technique it looks like no one can tell
[Music]
but I'm just constantly taking out those
Jenga pieces
okay so we're all working at her level
but nobody should be working with bad
biomechanics that's the baseline
everyone here is in decent fitness and
now it's time to make sure
accept the fact you cannot do whatever
there is a formula off to keep okay now
so I'm just explaining the process it
takes a long time to get it would give
you some clues that you might find
beneficial the taking away of agenda
pieces is release release the tension
release the idea but you kind of end up
with at the end is I don't know why my
hand is out there in space because it
seems when you have a reason to give to
your mind like what's keeping it out
there you're putting Jenga blocks in
there you get it
of course there's things that are
working I'm giving you the tools to get
there I don't have not a doctrine here
to explain how it works okay i'm not a
physicist here exact how do i do it okay
and it seems the more you try to do it
the more you add this level thing
biomechanical things okay
so we're going to do the same drills
some of us are going to be working on
biomechanical soundless and some of us
are going to be working on that mystery
we're going to move now okay so let me
show you the movement keep from doing
this you want if you want your hand out
here in space you take this whole unit
and you move it out of here
so I'm if I want my arm to draw I don't
this my pelvis aims wash my body look
look in here you see that I wanted it to
turn turn my pelvis want it down pelvis
want it up right I'm here so I'm going
to move trying to keep this relationship
got it
my arm he's not going to move separate
and see I lost a relationship my
shoulder is not going to come out of
that lock position my pelvis is not
going to brace in the back okay I start
the same and now watch here I move it
here here stays locked move
that would rank all this wrong and this
is why most you could not reject
yesterday as you are disconnecting
without having the higher skill or
structure does not mom right now
structure models okay so keep the shape
move the shapes okay let's try it
I'm sorry for those who I'm going to
take Jenga pieces down first thing I can
do is try to do this it doesn't matter
where you know there's no
you
come closer closer okay let's just look
at the shoulder pocket because here's
where a lot of your object in it
projection energy comes out okay so you
take your shoulder pocket it's about do
you see where I am
let's leave that shoulder here and put
my arm back out so just watch my that
was my shoulder pocket do you see that
I'm using that phrase to describe this
angle positioning of the shoulder that's
locked okay I'm just doing this so if I
leave by torso here on my arm swings
look it came changed you see that or I
lets-a-go didn't change didn't change
but now I'm gonna go like this changed
do you see that
if I walk my hand here right I'm going
to have to turn it do you see turn it
and move you see that
so that's what I'm doing at the end all
you pay attention to the shoulder I
wanted it out there I've moved a whole
unit up there right I wanted to come
around I have to turn my hat so that
shoulder stays there
if this spot was not enough I had to
turn my whole button do you see them but
do you know all that your solar change
it changed you're here and then at this
point a lot of you want to just knock
the guy down and you changed it do you
see that sometimes you're pretty good
you're here like that you kind of got up
and then you go like that
and you changed it okay so leave the
form for the other people the way you
feel it is to leave the form okay that's
what I mean so I kind of don't care by
anything I want to test myself
taking people he will trigger me that's
why it's a psychological thing
he will trigger me and I would put those
pieces so when you trigger to me okay
that's not purely physical so when I say
releasing that's what I'm going to use a
spiritual psychological emotional
letting go I can't I don't even know
what I'm letting go off to tell you the
truth because I don't understand how
it's doing it I just know if I release
then I'm now working with something else
okay
okay so right now I'm going to explain
to you why you want to move further
obviously you saw that there's more
workload and then there's more energy
conservation okay those are good skills
provided okay but here is because this
one I called it while mechanically sound
remember okay and what you didn't
realize is bio mechanically sound from a
particular vector only by default it's
on sound from every other vector you get
it otherwise you could do anything and I
said you can't do anything okay so he
goes there you go you see okay so it's
the same thing
the second I try to do this externally
we're going to call next Girona I can't
do it oh well I didn't know why the
other one works so probably were a few
more places than the other one so when
we're here so it's almost the workload
capacity I would say is smaller in
importance because any movement that I
have to do has to maintain integrity
through space you see that and if it
only maintains integrity on a particular
vector I'm probably not going to
maintain integrity as I travel through
space okay because forces start acting
upon me in many many different
directions all right so the more pieces
you take out the more external pieces
you take out and it's still able to
maintain integrity the more vectors you
can actually still maintain integrity
good bye okay
you